l'interview avec lui était prévu et il
me dit monter dans la voiture on fera
l'interview chemin et moi j'ai pas
d'interview à faire de lui alors
est-elle en observatrice
ça a duré plus de 100 kilomètres pendant
5 km et l'été séducteur ils étaient les
mains absolument magnifique
les mots peszko c'était un nom il a été
très correct mais il a brillé
il m'a parlé pendant 150 cas alors dans
plus de 100 km à 10 1 sera le but de
rafler se passer quelque chose ou pas à
moi en 74 je le trouvais je ne pouvais
pas peur j'ai eu très très bien très
très bien et quand on est arrivé j'ai
pas dit un mot il a parlé tout le temps
et quand on est arrivé il m'a mis la
main sur le bras et me dis franchement
votre conversation était très
intéressant
j'ai pris un flash dans la figure et
donc je me suis mise à pleurer il est
allé vers un de ces nombreux conseillers
les dix sept jeunes filles quand même
très très émotive parce qu'un petit
voyage et elle pleure déjà faire
l'interview s'est fait virer du coup la
vraie meuf qui devait interviewer mais
nous avons terminé parce que quand j'ai
dit est survenue avec physique j'avais
une voiture la mort d'un agent n'ai rien
senti un peu long allez merci bernard
appelle des 51 personnes
on va voir tout non je voulais revenir
ces rumeurs vous savez personne âgée à
côté là dessus
il y avait une rumeur sur lui comme quoi
il aurait eu une liaison avec la
princesse lady di la presse qu'il avait
écrit il avait écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelait la princesse et le président
mais c'était une fiction
il m'a amené jacques chirac a douté il
ya posez la question franchement est ce
que c'est vrai que vous avez eu une
relation avec la princesse diana est
évidemment il a dit non c'était de la
pure invention pour attirer l'anecdote
d'isabelle merci pour sa famille ces
externalités notre président quand même
de 74 à 80 lits